hi this is Evan Carmichael and today I'm
gonna do a special video and instead of
the usual me on camera I thought it
easier answer this one by doing some
screen captures of my computer so it's a
question today from David Hurley who's
an active member in our forums and he's
asking how do you check your Google
rankings so the question that came up
and he's saying that your Google
rankings are really responsive to your
own search history so it's really hard
to check from your own computer how well
you're actually ranking so he says his
way around it is to go to other
computers like going to libraries for
example or checking through bings but
he's one of there's a better way to
check Google rankings so yes there is
and I want to quickly show you a couple
of quick tricks that hopefully can help
you so the first thing I'll do a search
term for something on my own site I'll
type in famous entrepreneurs and I am
logged in how you can tell is here it
should say your name if you are logged
in and what this will do is keep track
of your own search results and try to
show you things that you might be
interested in so here you can see that
one of my pages rank and this is a
famous entrepreneur trading card set
that we created I'm gonna give that a +1
while we're here and you can see that
I've visited this page eight times
before and so they're gonna show it to
me again
the other way around this if you want to
log out you can just click here and then
go logout or I might use incognito mode
which is a setting within Chrome with
whoever uses Chrome and it'll load and
inspect need a browser and from here you
could type it in famous entrepreneurs
again and you can see here that I'm not
signed in so it says sign and give me
the option but I'm not actually listed
for that search term anymore so because
I'm logged in is showing me results that
are skewed so that's what David's asking
about and he's wondering if there's
another way around it so to help answer
the question this is not necessarily the
best way to do it because it's also
finding that I am based in Toronto
Ontario Canada where I am so it's also
going to try to show me results that are
skewed towards the Canadian market which
I may not necessarily want if I'm
targeting an international audience it
also by default goes to Google
see a which again skews towards the
Canadian market so you want to make sure
that at least you're taking pages from
the webinar pages from Canada but if
you're changing the location then every
time it's going to be specific to
whatever location you're in so the best
way that I use that I know of to check
for your rankings is actually through
your Google Webmaster Tools so if I load
that up so this is the webmaster tools
for me here's my account you can see
some of the stats that have come in
through searches for the past month what
you can do is click on your site on the
web and then click to search queries and
this is data right from Google so I
don't know of any better data that you
can get that's not straight from
Google's mouths most of the other tools
or third-party tools that aren't
necessarily accurate so what I'll do
here is it'll show you some of the most
popular keywords at your site's ranking
for you can go top queries top pages but
if you use your filters you can go use
famous entrepreneurs type that in and
what it's going to tell you here is how
many queries that I've had that use that
key phrase so you can see the list here
and it will tell you at least for my
main keyword here I've had two thousand
impressions which is down a little bit
and my average position is 69 so I'm not
ranking very well for that key phrase
but when I am logged in I'm ranking
within the the first page so this is the
best method that I know again it'll tell
you what your average position is so
that'll be skewed some people will see
it more than others but if you want to
find out what your true ranking is this
will give you your best indication is
directly from Google's data and it's
free as long as you have your Google
Webmaster Tools account set up the other
thing I'd recommend is that you try to
get more social as much as you can a lot
of the ranking factors now are going to
be skewed towards the relationships that
you have in social networks so if I do a
quick example if I go back here and I
type in my name
then you'll see that my website pops up
here for my name which would make sense
and you'll see that underneath of the
list people who've shared it so Maria
was a contact of mine she works for me
she shared it here on the site this is
my belt page you see that I shared it
and that Lisa shared it and that lots of
other people have shared it as well and
so the results are going to start being
skewed towards people who are in your
network and you want to make sure that
the people in your network are sharing
as much as possible so it increases the
chance of you ranking for different
keywords and why this is really
important it does this for +1 and also
will do it for Twitter right now why
it's really important if somebody gives
your site a +1 for example who's really
influential in a tight network of where
your customers are so you don't
necessarily need to be ranking number
one across the entire globe but if
there's a particular group of people who
you're trying to target a really niche
target audience if you get somebody
who's influential in that group to say
and give you a +1 or to tweet about your
webpage then you're gonna rank higher
for anybody who's in their contacts
which is great because it's all your
target audience so you might not be
ranking number one across the board but
it doesn't matter because you're
targeting your specific audience and
it's a quick way to jump to the first
page where otherwise might be super
difficult so it could change your
strategy to try to target really
influential people who are targeting
your ideal customer and audience one
last thing I want to talk about is the
new Google+ and there's a feature that
you can do to make your your Plus Ones
public which most people haven't done
yet and by default is turn off maybe
they're going to change this in the
future but I would encourage
entrepreneurs to turn it on because as
you're using it and sharing it you one
of the people you will see what you're
sharing because you can also share your
website and make that public so if I go
to my Google+ this is your standard view
if you click on your profile
so put in your face go profile you'll
see on mine that I have plus ones here
listed where most people don't so if I
load someone who's in my circle here
you'll see that by default these things
are turned off so what you want to do is
turn them on so that people can see all
the stuff that you're sharing and link
to your website of course so the easy
way to do it you just click on the plus
ones that you'll see and where is the
option I haven't done this for a while
in here oh sorry edit profile then
you'll see here show this tab on your
profile so you want to click that off
and then save it and that'll help make
sure that anybody who comes sees your
profile you've turned it on and that
you're publicly sharing the information
and your face will also show up under
different posts that you like so back to
the original question David I hope that
helps I would use webmaster tools as
much as possible to find out the exact
queries and where you're ranking the
average position it'll show you how many
clicks you get how much it's changed
over time and I would also encourage you
to try to get more social and try to
reach specific people who are authority
leaders who are targeting your ideal
customer base and get them to try to
share it to help you rank for where your
big customers are searching I hope that
helps if you guys liked the video please
give it a thumbs up below and leave a
comment I'd love to hear your thoughts
and feedback and stay tuned for the next
video
you